the title of your book is capital
punishment the hard truth about
Washington corruption from America's
most notorious lobbyists a frank title
for a frank book and in this book you
detail events that do not always reflect
positively on you including specifics
about the lobbying abuses that led to
your felony conviction and imprisonment
what prompted you to write this book
well two things first I thought it was
important that I present to the country
and to the readers what really happens
in Washington I'd gone through quite a
journey from the time I was a lobbyist
until the time I landed in prison in
terms of rethinking the world I was in
and my role in it and decided that while
I was in prison that I should take a
different approach to this world maybe
try to do something about it and part of
that would be to talk about it and talk
about the kind of things that most
people kind of suspect but they don't
really get to know because they don't
get to go behind the doors into the
rooms that I was in and hear the
conversations that I heard as a lobbyist
and be able by doing that to enable
America to have a true assessment of
what their government is at least in
part and had become the second reason I
did it was when my case became very
public and there were hearings and all
sorts of news articles in fact there
were so many news articles at the
beginning I started collecting them into
a folder in my computer frankly thinking
this wouldn't last long and not might as
well save all the articles I'm in and it
became almost a kind of dollars ritual
every morning that I would go and get
all the articles from the internet and
put them in a folder and by the time I
went to prison there were over 10,000
different articles about me and yet
because I didn't speak and I didn't give
really a window into my life I had
become kind of an evil cartoon and I
didn't help myself with wearing a hat
coming out of my plea in court and but I
had become kind of a villain and I
wanted to show people I'm not an evil
person I'm
regular-person I did things are wrong
but I don't have a tail or horns I'm
grew up like everybody else or maybe not
like everybody else that have kids have
a wife have a family and I felt it
important to at least tell from my
perspective what did happen you describe
being almost shocked when you first came
to Washington having worked for and
headed to college Republicans when you
went to lobby for funding for the MX
missile and a member of Congress says to
you well I can deliver more than a dozen
votes for you if you arrange for me to
have a naval base in my district and you
describe feeling very kind of tainted by
that what was it like when you first
started out in Washington and what were
your initial reactions well what
happened was I was first hitting the
college Republicans and during that
period of time we were political group
political wing of the student wing of
the Republican Party and you know we
were activists and kind of wacky and
wild and good things to instigate
trouble and whatnot on the campuses and
organized Republicans when I became head
of President Reagan's grassroots lobby
that's when I experienced this moment
with the congressman Bustamante where he
said if you enable us to have this base
in my district organize a the votes and
I was shocked by that I you know I guess
you hear about it you see it on TV see
it in the movies but to see it in person
at first for me as a young man I was
very young in my early 20s I was very
surprised by that and didn't really
encounter a lot of that until I returned
to Washington about ten years later as a
lobbyist you describe your life is a
Washington lobbyist in pretty candidate
terms and you describe out one of the
ways you gained influences you would
extend job offers to congressional aides
and that even before they left those
congressional offices they would have
you in mind and that you felt you
effectively had control of that office
describe how that worked well first when
I started building my lobbying practice
I started to look for people to hire
when I joined the lobbying firm Preston
gates initially I was the only person
there
who had not worked on Capitol Hill in
fact during the meetings initial
meetings there one of the fellows
suggested that I go back to go to
Capitol Hill and get a job well I wasn't
interested in doing that at that point
in my life but everybody else had worked
on Capitol Hill so when the time came to
hire other lobbyists my practice was
growing I needed people to help I went
to Capitol Hill and month among my
friends now first the first couple hires
I had came immediately to me they didn't
wait even a week they gave notice and
they joined right away so I didn't
really notice anything but as I started
to hire more and more folks and I
started to look at some of the players
on Capitol Hill mainly the staff and
think gosh I really hope I can get her
or him to join my practice when I'd
mentioned it I noticed that at that
moment once they read they would start
to have in mind where they were gonna go
in a year or two which is I guess only
natural people start thinking about
their next job and I noticed that I had
an amazing power on them and on their
office all the sudden they became in
essence our agents and in fact more than
our agents they thought of things that
benefited us and our clients that we
couldn't even think of perhaps as a way
of making sure they feather their nest
before they got there and in your book
you describe this as one of the biggest
problems with the system in Washington
right it's one it's one of the problems
in terms of the corruption and it's also
it's not to say that everybody who's
hired by the way is doing this I'm not
trying to nothing I say is applicable to
everybody but the fact that people can
go in the revolving door from public
service into cashing in and becoming
much more wealthy frankly joining a
lobbying firms or doing whatever they do
it's a problem I think is a source of
corruption and it's something which I as
a lobbyist started to use I knew after a
while after a couple years of this that
I was strategically plan ahead for the
business and I would try to hire the
people who I thought while they stayed
there they'd be a big help to us while
they were there as well so it's a source
of corruption it's it's something it's
not something people focus on they are
starting to focus on it after I wrote
about it but people don't generally know
about this outside of Washington and
it's a very big source of control you
also describe
how you charged clients including Indian
tribes up to 150,000 a month even though
other many other lobbyists are charging
about a tenth of that fee describe how
you came to represent so many Indian
tribes what you did for them and how
these payments came to be held against
you well I probably at no time that I
represent more than they have a dozen
tribes and once our representations of
our clients very different than most
lobbying firms most lobbying firms go
and ask client for ten fifteen thousand
a month and they do some things for them
and they can't engage at those prices
and big fights the people who hired me
were in life-threatening bites there
were people who were either about to get
put out of business or they were folks
when I was originally hired by the
Choctaw tribe Mississippi band of
Choctaw Indians he was because the
Republican Congress was about to pass a
unrelated business income tax that would
have taken 30% of the gross revenue of
these tribes and all the lobbyists that
they had working on it which were
Democrats at that point 1995 they
couldn't stop this thing so I was hired
and brought in to do that initially I
was a law firms and so law firms charged
their clients based on the amount of
hours that individual people in the firm
spend on the case and they add up those
hours and they multiplying by the hourly
rate that these people use and that's
how they come to their monthly bill
well the Choctaw fight got very intense
we won the first go-round and then there
were more rounds and more fights and
hearings and this and that and the bill
was getting up there pretty high and I
noticed that the bill was averaging out
at about a hundred fifty thousand
dollars a month and so the other clients
who came on had similar situation and
ultimately I got to understand that when
we went to war unlike what a small lot
most lobbying firms do where they do
some research and they do a few meetings
we would literally run legislative
fights and the entire Congress and
hearings and there's a full-on effort
the time that we were put in the time
that the people who work for me and I
had upwards of about 40 people working
for me at some point
the time they would put in multiplied by
the time the law firm charged out
generally wound up to be on an average
basis around that number so subsequent
clients when I brought when I they came
to me with their problems I explained
what we would do explain the kind of
activities we'd be involved in and I
told him this would be the price and
they were and threatened to lose
hundreds of millions of dollars a year
so I think they felt that a couple
million dollars a year in terms of the
law fees were probably worth it and they
were we usually won and yet you have
been asked to pay restitution to I have
because I has indeed it you know I pled
and the matter of restitution was part
of the package there when I was done
lobbying when my career was over uh sat
back and added up the fees that we
collected and the benefits that we had
provided the money we had saved them the
taxes we had stopped from being put on
them the land that we helped them get
into their control as tribal reservation
land and try to place some value
conservative value on it and for about
eighty million dollars or so in fees
that the firm's and I charged we figure
we delivered about six billion dollars
in value so in that to me was the
measure of my representation of my
clients and by the way the reason my
clients continued to hire me year after
year I didn't have contracts like most
law lobbying firms do most lobbying
firms have a contract saying you've got
hires for a year or two years and no
matter what you can't break that
contract my deal with my clients was if
you don't like me fire me that afternoon
and you don't owe me a thing going
forward
in fact I had one client which was a
foreign country who wanted us to
represent them they wanted to give some
port to the US to create a naval base
and we were lobbying to get the u.s. to
take that place and maybe set up a US
naval base there we've been very
strategic in the country of Eritrea and
unfortunately Eritrea was in the
practice at that point once we started
representing they started arresting
members of the staff of the US Embassy
who were eretrians but they arresting
them and holding them without charges
and the state department office
he was very upset about this I went to
them and said listen you know you got to
charge them or let them go you know we
in this country we don't do that and
they said well in our country we do do
that so I said I can't represent you any
longer because I can't do anything for
you and I offered to give him back all
their money because I hadn't achieved
what what we had achieved they said that
they couldn't do it because they made
those government payments but that was
my attitude toward my clients if I
didn't deliver value for them I didn't
want to be paid by them describe handing
a senator an envelope of contributions
and being told the Indian Affairs
Committee you would treat your clients
well and you say in the book that well
campaign money is a problem it's not the
only problem or even the main problem
what is the main problem in your view
well campaign money is certainly part of
the main problem the main problem and
there are four main problems that
identify in terms of solutions in the
book to some of the corruption the
overall problem by the way is the
federal government's too big the federal
government send too many things their
30,000 or whatever the number is
lobbyists running around because there
need to be 30,000 lobbyists running
around the government some bomb hundreds
of thousands of things that far exceed
any vision of this country from the past
so that's the reason that this industry
is growing continually there's never a
bad year in the lobbying industry as
there's never a bad year by the way and
around this town and so but what I feel
is if you're not going to be able to
reduce the size of government
immediately then the money that gets
involved the campaign contributions in
the one hand and then also the
gratuities and meals and trips and
tickets to ballgames and everything else
however one gets them through the
loopholes that are left on the law any
of these things ultimately unfortunately
come down to being bribes I know it's
not polite to say that I certainly
didn't think of when I was in there but
I'm not quite sure how else one looks at
it if you're giving a public servant
something of value and you want that
public server to do something for you I
don't know how you characterize it as
anything else at this point in my life
that's number one number two the
revolving door between public service
and cashing in and whether one's cashing
in as a lobbyist or a strategic adviser
or history professor or whatever the the
euphemism of the day is
it's still cashing in and I think
miracle looks at this and sees folks
show up in this town worth twenty
thousand dollars and leaving at worth
twenty million dollars and they're
scratching their heads wondering you
know we lose our jobs we don't have any
food on the table meanwhile these guys
are getting rich so I think that that's
another thing the other the other two
that I think can go after the corruption
one is term limits I have to tell you
the lobbyists I was against term limits
and I used to pretend or at least
convinced myself that I was against term
limits because you want to have people
have the right to vote for whomever they
want and there's a value to having
people in town a long time well both of
those are not true the truth is a lot of
you stumble on term limits because the
lobbyists don't want to go by a
congressman's office twice if you have a
congressman that you made a relationship
with through these unfortunate methods
you don't have to start all over after a
new election and so I think term limits
are important in terms of getting new
blood through this town and then finally
the other thing I talk about in the book
is a prescription one of the main pillar
prescriptions is trying to get these
guys to apply every law they make to
themselves recently we've seen this
insider trading scandal but we know
there are other laws that they're also
not applied to these folks and they
should be applied it's not right how do
you send a guy like Raj Rajaratnam to
prison for 11 years for insider trading
at the same time a member if he were a
member of Congress he wouldn't have to
go anywhere I think that's not fair it's
not right and so the laws they make need
to be applied to themselves when you
speak about the campaign contributions
and you use the term bribery mm-hmm also
in the book and I wanted to quote
briefly you say we've described at one
point a particular senator you were told
would support you if he received a
$5,000 check for the campaign and as you
described it of course neither of
because neither I was considered for a
moment that this contribution was in
fact merely a bribe so are you saying
that campaign contributions are bribes
and is this type of exchange common on
Capitol Hill well it's very common it's
coming all over town all over Washington
I don't think it's a bribe if you're a
citizen and you care about your
government and you want to give money in
whatever amount to somebody's running
for Congress or the Senate or the
and you're doing it for the betterment
of the country you're doing for sort of
macro issues but if you're doing it
because you want to get an earmark or
you're doing it because you want to get
a tax break or you're doing because you
want to get a grant or a contract or
things like that I don't see how that's
not a private you describe the
restaurant that you started' signatures
becoming a virtual cafeteria and
fundraising hub for groups of members of
Congress and their staff you described
you showered the staff with gifts and
with meals and tickets to sporting
events I think you've said you spent 1.5
million a year on sporting event tickets
and you also described the notorious
Scotland trip where you played on the
Old Course at st. Andrews under the
lobbying and ethics reforms passed after
you were convicted all of that would now
be illegal do you believe the lobbying
and ethics reforms put in place after
you left Washington have improved the
system I think they've marginally
improved it but I don't think they've
solved it there's still many many
loopholes I'll give you an example I
can't take a member to lunch and buy
them hamburger for $25 or whatever the
price hamburgers are in this town but if
I declare that lunch a fundraising lunch
and I pull out of my pocket five five
thousand dollar checks and I say you
know we're having a fundraising lunch
here's the checks I can buy the
hamburger and I can then have the same
conversation that's a loophole that's a
way around it so there there are many
loopholes still and I think what we see
is we see reform go through where they
take away certain things but ultimately
they're not making systemic changes
which is what has got to happen there's
got to be a shutting of the door no
conveyance of anything of value we'd
seen people lobbying or people
importuning the government and trying to
get benefits for themselves or their
companies or their communities or
whatever they're doing no financial
conveyance to a public servant at all
not a dollar not a pickle not a glass of
water nothing at the time you were under
scrutiny on Capitol Hill you were quoted
as saying that you were being pilloried
for activities that were commonplace in
the lobbying world do you distill
believe that's true well unfortunately I
think that
but I was pilloried for 90% of it was
legal 10% of it I went over the line
maybe 10% or less at the time now I went
to prison for those things but most of
what I did was legal and most of what
everybody else is doing here is legal I
don't accuse others of breaking the law
I'm I guess I'm accusing the entire
system of being over the line not the
legal line but the appropriate line and
so in that respect yes people certainly
are doing what I did I didn't invent
anything I didn't create the idea of
taking people golfing or to meals or to
sporting events or any of that I just
overdid it I had my own restaurant I had
my own plane you know I overdid it and
and I crossed the lines and what about
the lobbying industry today what is your
opinion of it and what works or doesn't
work about the way lobbying is conducted
now in Washington well I think that it's
important to note that there are many
many good Muslims who are fine probably
not doing anything wrong or illegal nor
untoward in any way I don't have numbers
and percentages but my experience was
that most of the lobbyists play on a
sort of much more quiet scale than I did
and that some of the bigger folks do
that doesn't mean that the kind of
things I did are not going on today they
are and there was a lobbyist who was
indicted and sent to prison after me
after my scandal continued doing it so
people don't really learn when they see
somebody like me go down it's more like
and I try to liken it to your driving on
the road and all of a sudden you see a
terrible car wreck and their bodies
strewn all over the place and as you
drive by you slow down and you look at
that and you're scared for a little bit
and the next mile you're perfect you're
not breaking any laws you're you're just
unbelievable five miles down the road
you've forgotten it already and you're
back to speeding and I think the best
sort of what goes on here one of the
things you talk about in the book is
your life as an Orthodox Jew and the
Jews charities you gave money to and a
question arises given your commitment to
Jewish morals you know how did you land
at the center of one of this decades
most celebrated ethics controversies
you know it's interesting when I was
doing when I was a lobbyist I actually
didn't think I was doing anything wrong
I thought I was in the doing what
everybody does maybe I was aggressive
and pushing out of love and that was my
personality I was a hyper aggressive
person my whole life but I didn't really
quite see where I was in this forest for
these trees that's my own fault I think
I liken it to sometimes when you set off
on a voyage on a ship and you have a
sextant and if your sextant is one small
degree off base that's not going to
notice that at the beginning you may not
even notice in the middle of your trip
but by the time you're done your trip
you're on a place you never even dreamed
you wind up and that's sort of what
happened with me unfortunately I lost I
lost sight of what I believed and what I
what I knew a lot of it had to do with
the competition of my wanting to win I
had too much of a desire to never lose
for my clients I loved the competition I
played rough our guys played rough if
you attack one of my clients and you
were from Capitol Hill you would expect
us to come after you in your election we
we were a very thuggish group of
lobbyists I'm sorry to say but that kind
of aggression and that kind of activity
unfortunately was made normal to me by
the fact that I thought I was protecting
clients whom I loved and who I basically
supported all their issues you know my
made a lot of money for them and for me
my wife and I gave away 80% of the money
we made a charity and community causes
so it's not like I was unfortunately for
my current situation it's not like I
invested it wisely although I guess one
could say that helping people is not a
bad investment
so while doing all that I thought I was
doing good stuff I looked at other
lobbyists and thought you know you take
10,000 a month from this poor client and
lead them down the primrose path they'd
get defeated they get in trouble they
don't win and you don't care your
attitude is well I'll just get another
client with us our attitude was we are
gonna live or die with our client if our
client loses we don't come back alive
that literally was the ethos for better
worse in our office and so looking at
all that while I'm in the middle of that
forest I thought I was the moral
lobbyist this is the I hate my life I
not only didn't think I was in tomorrow
I thought I was moral unfortunately I
had gone so far far off the path that
that was my perception you do say
looking back you should have been
bothered by how often staff members whom
you asked for help returned with
requests for political contributions and
now reform advocates say the solution is
public financing do you agree I don't I
don't agree first of all I don't trust
any government program to be honest with
you first of all I had the privilege of
living under the government auspices for
43 months so I got up close and personal
with a lot of government employees and
I'm not certain I want them running too
much although they treated me all right
you know at the end and in that place
I'm nervous about public financing for a
lot of reasons first of all the
Jeffersonian reason of not taking
somebody's money and spending it on an
audiological thing that they don't
believe in which i think is ultimately
philosophically a problem there second
of all we're at a time where we need to
cut back the government not increase the
government expenditures and third of all
whenever you open up a government
program where you're spending money
guess who shows up ultimately the
lobbyists somebody's gonna show up and
try to get control of that money that is
human nature I would much rather see a
total bar on the people whose money in
the system is sullying the system see I
don't view it that somebody who's out
there who just cares about the country
and wants to give away all their money
to politics because that's what they
like I don't view that as a problem if
they're not asking for things and if
it's revealed and disclose who they are
if they're not asking for anything
they're just giving their money because
they believe in people I think that's
good I think that's what this country
should have been I'm not in favor of
people who are like I was who was giving
money and raising money to get something
that is the problem and I don't think
campaign public financing it certainly
sort of addresses that but to me it
creates a different problem a different
potential for corruption that I don't
want to say many are angry at Washington
right now both on the left and the right
do you think they have a right to be and
should Congress respond well they should
wake up for openers they have a nine
percent approval rating that should tell
them something right there but you
rarely hear them even worry about that
they have these things like the insider
trading laws and they don't understand
why they're so unpopular they don't
understand the people look at them and
they look at what they're doing and they
look at the money they make and the
power they wield over everybody's lives
and they resent it and we don't have a
monarchy in this country but we
certainly have something close in terms
of the Congress and and and some degree
the White House you recommend the
government lawmakers sign a clean up the
government pledge not unlike Grover
Norquist's anti-tax pledge why
well it's effective whether one supports
the pledge that Americans for Tax Reform
facilitated for members to sign or not
nobody can deny it's effective now I
don't believe that Republicans aren't
raising taxes only cause the grover's
pledge people forget that not raising
taxes is a primary tenet of the
Republican Party see what he's done
though is concretize it into an actual
pledge so that if somebody breaks that
to their constituents and to their
voters they can hold them accountable
and what I propose is a similar thing
with good government let's come up with
changes that are gonna fix the system
and let's demand of our legislators and
those who are running for these seats
that they sign this pledge that they're
gonna vote for they're gonna co-sponsor
and they're gonna do everything they can
to push through legislation that in acts
these kind of changes and frankly takes
away their percocets in terms of this
this life both in Congress and
afterwards and hold them to it and if
they don't do it kick them out you
describe having met Grover Norquist's as
a college Republican I believe Ralph
Reed as well describe what the role that
these two men played in your life and
the role they play now well Grover and I
met he was a student at Harvard Business
School I was a student at Brandeis I had
just become the head of the college
Republicans up there and Grover was
active in the organization and together
we organized Massachusetts for the
Reagan campaign
nineteen eighty and worked very hard and
had all sorts of adventures and hijinks
that I wrote about in the book some of
which were pretty funny and basically at
the end of it we won Massachusetts as a
group everybody was involved but they
were kind enough and generous enough to
party to credit us that we provided the
difference we registered gosh
several thousand absentee ballot 'add
college Republicans whose votes at the
end of the day made the difference in a
three or four thousand boat victory in
that state so Grover and I went through
that together after that Grover
suggested to me to run for national
chairman of college Republicans he had
had some involvement with Karl Rove and
others of the past and were friends with
them I didn't know anybody I just come
out of California and went to Brandeis
and so Grover was my campaign manager
and then when I won in 1981 came as my
executive director and stayed with me
through that year before he went off to
do other stuff he returned with me we
reunited under President Reagan's Lobby
where he was the field director and then
he went off the found Americans for tax
reform which has been immensely
effective Grover and I haven't been in
touch much during this grover's
unfortunately for him had tremendous
scrutiny all quarters people seem to get
mad at him over the tax thing and blame
him for the budget supercommittee
business and so he tries to I think keep
his head down a little bit and so we've
not had much contact but I consider him
to be a friend and I haven't been in
touch with him but that's okay he's got
other battles to fight what about Ralph
Reed Ralph came to the convention I work
I was elected at 1981 as a very young
man a teenager and came to work for us
lived in my apartment on the couch we
couldn't afford to pay more than $100 a
month in those days we had no money
Grover Harvard MBA was making $1,000 a
month and I was making $1,000 a month as
well and Ralph got $100 a month so he
lived on my couch
he became executive direct
eventually had a religious epiphany and
went off to then work for Pat Robertson
ultimately at Christian Coalition built
the organization into an incredible
operation Ralph played a role in our
efforts to stop casinos in the south his
depiction of his role caused him trouble
later as he you know didn't necessarily
describe things precisely correctly and
it wound up probably costing him a
lieutenant governor's race I had been in
touch with Ralph since then well thank
you and we're gonna go to a break now
and we'll be back shortly on the go
afterwards is available via podcast
through iTunes and XML visit book tv.org
and click podcasts on the upper left
side of the page select which podcast
you'd like to download and listen to
afterwards while you travel at the very
beginning of this book you describe how
your Trek to a Senate hearing felt like
a death march and I want you to talk a
little bit about the series of events
that began in 2003 after articles in The
Washington Post began to appear that
questioned the amount of money the
tribes were paying you raised questions
about your involvement in a casino
cruise line business venture known as
sand cruise that fell apart under
questionable circumstances that was the
beginning of a whole chain of events
that you described which are almost a
archetypal Washington crisis and
unfolding of a scandal where you're
under this microscope and you know you
were fired from your lobbying firm you
weren't investigated by federal
prosecutors you were called to testify
on Capitol Hill
you were pilloried by the news media
what was all that like for you it was
horrible it at first when it started as
I as I mentioned I thought this would
probably blow over
after a couple weeks I didn't think
there was anything to it the article in
The Washington Post which came out at
the beginning of March I guess in 2004
or into February the article said I
charged my clients a lot of money there
are
girls on the front page of the New York
Times in the Wall Street Journal that
said the same thing yes I did charge
with my clients a lot of money this
reporter who came to see me for the
Washington Post
I gave her an interview tried to explain
to her what we did for our clients there
was a much interest in hearing that so
the information that I compiled didn't
get in the article but when the article
first came out frankly there was an
email back report with the firm saying
should we post the article on our
website all it really does is talk about
how you know it's claiming we're ripping
off our clients but our clients know
better than that and what do we you know
it'll be over with soon but then Senator
McCain got into action and subpoenaed
all my emails and started a serious
investigation from the Senate side
unfortunately it seems this
investigation involved some of my rival
lobbyists he actually wrote a letter to
the chief of one of the tribes lauding
the work of one of my rival lobbyists in
the investigation so it seemed to me
that at first that it would go away and
then when it was clear wasn't gonna go
away I thought well gosh why am I
getting picked on here what's the what's
this all about I'm just doing what
everybody does right oh why is mine is
this a problem surely they are after
obviously quickly I was fired by my law
firm and people started to you know
treat me with a little bit of disdain or
a lot of disdain and there were more
articles that seemed like everyday
broader an article on the front page of
the post it was extremely difficult as
you can imagine for my family and seeing
the paper get there every day and there
I am on the front page of it and
eventually I started to look into hired
an attorney had a brilliant attorney
named Abby Lowell who started going
through with me my emails and all of
what I read and I wrote 850,000 emails
over the less than a decade that I was a
lobbyist so I kind of had diarrhea the
fingers and there were plenty of emails
there and Senator McCain's committee was
sort of parsing through them to find
those that were boneheaded
salacious and things like that and
knocking him out to the Washington Post
in the front page we complained we filed
a complaint to the Senate Ethics
Committee because that violates Senate
ethics if you're having an investigation
you're not supposed to leak it all to
the press but they didn't quite pay
attention to that one and so eventually
it became clear to me that I had crossed
lines and lines that I didn't set out to
cross lines and I didn't think I crossed
when I was doing it frankly I stopped
caring about the lines to be honest with
you while I was lobbying I just wanted
to win and I didn't understand what this
was all about and then eventually I
started figuring out what it was all
about and I saw that I had done things
that were wrong and when I did it
started shock me
to be honest with you I didn't
contemplate that I would ever have a
moment like that and then while I'm sort
of going through this personal journey
of figuring out what I did and where I
was there was a public Inquisition going
on and everything in my life was taken
negatively every aspect of my life even
the charity we did was was described in
pejorative terms and so eventually solve
different papers who like the LA Times
where I'd grown up out there in Beverly
Hills they had to have their cut at me
and so they went back and took my eighth
grade election when I ran for president
of the class in the eighth grade and
they recharacterized that as if this was
the beginning of my nefarious campaign
activities and they had another article
where when I played football I hit
linebacker once yeah pretty hard knocked
him out and they portrayed that as proof
that I was come some kind of villain as
if you're supposed to play football I
guess you're not supposed to hit people
and Kortney to them or something I don't
know him but anyway this was going on
and I was sinking and I just kept
falling and falling one during our
windows when does it stop but it never
stopped and it kept going and going it
stopped when I landed with a thud in
prison I was brought up to that hearing
you asked about and I described the
first part of the book and I pled the
fifth at the hearing
Senate hearings people ask me why'd you
plead the fifth sentient hearings aren't
sort of fair fora for judicial rights
the witnesses don't have rights in the
Senate in fact they have rules in the
Senate they don't even buy by them I'm
gonna give you an example when we got
there the first thing out of my
attorneys mouth a Bulow sat down and he
said you know senators I'd like to ask a
question a point of information and they
recognized him and he said you have a
rule that you made that if a Senate
hearing is likely to lead to the
indictment criminal indictment of a
witness or the besmirching of their
reputation this hearing has got to be in
Helton closed session that's your rule
now if there's a hearing that is more
likely to lead to an indictment of
somebody or to destroying their
reputation than this one I can't imagine
what it is but meanwhile you have this
hearing in the biggest room on Capitol
Hill you designed it to take place when
they were opening the Native American
museum so you could fill the room with
people who have been whipped up against
me and you have more cameras here than
the Super Bowl and this hearing should
be closed and the Senators kind of
looked at each other looked at him kind
of chuckled and kept going
so I knew that there wasn't going to be
a fair forum but what kind of got to me
while they were asking me questions was
the memories coming back to me of who
these guys were it a lot of them were
people who either I or people work for
me gave a lot of money to byron Dorgan
got $75,000 from people who work for me
or my clients senator Campbell who
chaired the committee claims he doesn't
remember now but I read in the book the
exact date of it we had a breakfast at
la colline restaurant which doesn't
exist anymore
where I handed him a bunch of checks he
was chairman of the Indian Affairs
Committee and he told me that our
clients would do very well in front of
his committee and so I'm thinking these
things as I'm watching these senators
ask me these horrific questions
insulting nasty questions and I'm
pleading the fifth over every one of
them and it got so bad to Senator McCain
who is my greatest things agonist
actually was the one who stepped forward
and said senators I think we better stop
this we're actually harassing this
witness no kidding and so they they
stopped and I got to leave but it was a
horrific experience as an for
this whole thing has been one of the
things that seems to really stick in
your mind was the way in which you were
pilloried for wearing a hat you're the
image of you wearing a hat as you exited
I believe that hearing it was when I
pled guilty in court tell us about that
well it was January 2006 and I knew from
the beginning I was going to plea
because as soon as I saw I was guilty of
things I didn't want to fight and create
a big spectacle and drag things out I
wanted to get through it and I wanted to
do what I thought would be right and so
I knew I was gonna play and I was
already cooperating and meeting with the
Justice Department as I did do for many
many days including after I went to
prison and the day came in January 4th I
think it was maybe six the 2006 when I
had to go to court now everywhere I went
the media would show up with their
cameras and they'd charge me and yell
things at me and make it as unpleasant
as the life can be and I really didn't
want that so I decided to go to court as
early in the morning as possible to beat
the media it was I think a hearing at
noon or 11:00 or something and I went at
6:00 in the morning and it was raining
and it was dark and I left that house
that January morning so it's raining so
I grabbed the raincoat and I grabbed a
rain hat people said it was some
Borsellino or some fancy hat it was a
rain hat a collapsible rain hat that I
had in my closet and I grabbed it and I
put it on and I walked in the rain and
went into court and then most people I'd
bring rain coats on and we're going in
there weren't a lot of people going in 6
the morning but folks who were including
my attorney had rain coats on and well
the hearing took place pled guilty I had
a lot of things on my mind that day not
my wardrobe and I walked out I put my
hat and coat on to leave and as I walked
out to the glare of the Sun and to the
glare of the cameras they started
screaming
now the folks who were taking pictures
they screamed terrible stuff at you and
the reason they do that is they want you
to look at them alright so that they
scream something more outrageous than
the other guy they figure you'll turn
around and look at them and that's the
goal well they were screaming stuff me
they said woo you a gangster are you
mafia and first I didn't know what they
were talking about and then I realized
that they had and I wanted to say what
are you talking about the last gangster
war had like this was George Raft and
the 40s but I didn't get to say anything
and I realized at that point I had a
wardrobe malfunction and I set myself up
unfortunately for a real problem but
that's what happened and I read about it
in the book and unfortunately that is
sort of become the image of me that
played right into the image of Boris
badenov the bad guy that mafiosi and
things like that and unfortunately in
life sometimes innocent things if you
don't think about them they can redound
to your detriment and that certainly did
do you think that you were treated
fairly well by whom a lot of people
treated me yes I do I do there's that me
a way to jail for a long time but I
thought they were incredibly
professional very thorough above
reproach and treated me with with great
dignity in the sense of they they were
professional I didn't experience with
some people experience of prosecutors
which is kind of harassment and
prosecutorial abuse the people who
worked on my case that I experienced
were nothing but professionals and I
appreciated them greatly being
professional it was a horrific thing I
knew eventually that I was going to end
up in prison and the prosecutorial team
and the Justice Department are obviously
the ones who put me there I put myself
there I guess but they were the ones who
were the operating side of it but even
saying even knowing that instead of
looking at them and hating them as
frankly most prisoners and felons hate
their prosecutors and their judge and
their even their lawyers and certainly
the FBI I don't hate anybody I'm I put
myself where I went
I regret it you described pacing the
track at the Cumberland Correctional
Facility and going over how could we
change the system what would you perform
what would you recommend as reforms what
was the hardest thing about being in
prison and what lessons if any did you
take away from your trial and
imprisonment
well I took so many lessons away if we
unless we have another hour on the cable
to go through all them but some of the
big ones were that you got to follow the
rules you can't ignore rules and now my
children probably don't like this
because I won't even drive over the
speed limit at this plain foot I didn't
have an attitude of all these rules are
important I thought they were basically
impediments and the ends justify the
means and that's not how life is and
unfortunately if you live life like that
and I did you wind up in trouble so
that's one big lesson I took away
I also took away the lesson of you
better see the forest for the trees or
you're gonna wind up buried by those
trees and I didn't step back and say you
know should I been in this should I be
doing this is there anything wrong with
what I'm doing I never had a moment like
that unfortunately in fact as I
mentioned quite the opposite I thought
it was a okay so one has to do that in
life in terms of walking the track in
prison and what the hell I was treated
in prison
I mean prison is horrible one day in
prison you wouldn't wish on your worst
enemy I was there for 1299 days and it's
horrible
unfortunately America gives us a lot of
prison time out to people there are
people in prison for a lot longer than I
was who were with me and it's a crushing
experience you not only taken away from
your family you're taken away from your
freedoms and you're stripped of
everything that you own and you're
basically become a number and you become
a slave if you work for 12 cents an hour
you have no privacy not one minute is a
privacy you're sharing our housing
cubicles we're 150 square feet and six
men lived in that hundred and fifty
square feet it's overcrowded it's noisy
it's just the most horrible place he
could ever be every minute I was in
prison I was praying to God to get me
out of prison
and thank God I mentioned
it happened looking back was there a
turning point where you went from
thinking that everything was okay to
realizing that it was very much not okay
yes the the turning point was when my
firm fired me up until that point I
thought we'll just fight through this
and everything will be okay and I
described the meeting and in the book
when they came in to see me and I
thought they were coming to tell me how
we're gonna turn this around and instead
they fired me and that was devastating
and that made me realize that I wasn't
probably coming back from this
I tried still to position myself to get
through it but at that point I probably
realized that this was not going to end
well if there's one thing you could do
differently what would it be well
there's not one thing I would do
differently there are many things but
again I'd follow I'd be careful to
follow every rule I'd be careful to make
sure that I didn't think that
information that I had that my clients
for example deserve to have to make
decisions was not necessary for them to
have there are a lot of things that I
would do differently I probably try to
if I could squelch this
hyper-competitive attitude I have that I
got a win win win no matter what
all those are destructive and and their
challenges and I'm hoping that I've
overcome a lot of them through the pain
I've been through but one never really
knows I guess until you put back into a
situation you predicted in your book
that the reforms that you proposed would
not be well-received by Washington
lobbyists and you're correct some of
them have told me they take umbrage that
you and they consider you responsible
for helping give lobbyists a bad name
would now come up with recommendations
for how to change the system does that
surprise you
no of course not the I am by the way had
a number of lobbyists friends could
there quietly my friends I told them be
quiet about being my friends or you're
not gonna have any other lobbyists as
your friends the lobbying world I think
very conveniently wanted to make it that
I was the one who besmirched the name
lobbyists I don't know
they've been for the last hundred 50
years I don't remember a minute when I
was a lobbyist the lobbyists had a good
reputation I certainly didn't help but I
wasn't the only one and I understand
that they now feel that I have no right
to come back and frankly go after the
system I'm not doing this to please them
or not please them I'm doing this
because I feel that I have information
that I can in some way of making some
recompense to the country who I feel
frankly a much greater fealty to than to
the lobbying world if I can do something
that can help clean up the system and
aid people and analyzing their
government then I'm going to do it I
understood by the way and I thought
about this that it could be very much
easier for me to just be quiet and go
away and not subject myself again to the
media scrutiny and not subject myself
certainly to the hill and to the
lobbying world and their scrutiny which
is intense
but I decided that that wouldn't be
right I went through this I need to do
something to make recompense I am paying
restitution probably be paying
restitution for the rest of my life
that's one thing I went to prison my
family basically lost everything my kids
suffered my wife suffered my father
suffered my mother passed away
certainly I paid a big price probably
rightfully so for what I did but there's
something positive I can do and I'm
gonna do it and if bunch of lobbyists
don't like it I don't frankly it doesn't
matter to me
they don't intimidate me I've been in
prison for 43 months I don't think they
should I think better some lobbyists on
K Street are gonna intimidate me and
you've been barred by the federal
government from being a lobbyist from
doing any business nothing being loved
is that what I was barred was that the
Interior Department barred me from being
a vendor not that I had any plans to be
a vendor but they when I got out they
put through a department of me from the
Interior Department I had no intention
to I don't intend to be a lot as either
if they barred me from being a lot as I
would be just fine but they didn't and I
don't think they can bar you from a
lobbyist yeah but you would not want to
be a loved it no I don't want to return
to a world where I rose the stop and
then at
had got off there plenty of other things
to do in life frankly I'd rather
dedicate myself to doing something good
in helping people in general so talk
about what steps you're taking to
promote changes in the system well I may
wrote the book and be I'm speaking about
it and I'm trying to answer questions
that people have because even people
read the book have a lot of questions
still and obviously I can put everything
in the book I'm trying to work with some
of the reform groups who by the way were
my biggest adversaries and enemies and
when I was going through this they were
the people who went after me the most
okay
that was their business and their job
but I've reached my hand out and said
okay I was that guy who used to be me
you know now I would go after him too so
let me try to be helpful if I can most
of them are delighted and want to have
me help but they can some are not some
some feel that I should name more names
and pork more people in jeopardy and I
don't want to do that even people I
don't like it's not to me about
individuals or people and destroying
lives and people don't think I think
when they want to destroy somebody's
life that they have children a family
and people love them and they suffer
more than they do but it's more than
that
the fact is every time we focus on a
Jack Abramoff and all pat ourselves on
the back that we throw him in prison and
he's dead and he's the he's the one who
destroyed lobbying and destroy
Washington we don't fix the system we
fix him and I got fixed there's no
question about it but the system didn't
get thanks and so what I'd prefer to do
is instead of focusing like that I'd
rather focus people on the system here
are specific things that if we change
them and we get people to change them
life will be a lot better for all of us
one of the things that you recommend
which is that lobbyists be barred from
making campaign contributions it's very
controversial
there are many lobbyists who say that's
unconstitutional
where do you think are the areas where
there's common ground with the lobbyists
within the reform community and even the
lobbying community I don't know that
there's common ground with a lot in
community I think what the lobbying
community generally wants to do now I'm
not talking about the lobbyist who's you
know who's out there just yeah honestly
honestly plying their trade I'm talking
about the powerful lobbyists who kind of
care about these things they don't want
to bail on a be barred from giving
contribution
don't even barred from taking people to
get dinners and things like that I don't
know that there is common ground because
ultimately they those people and I was
one of them use those tools to their
advantage to get a leg up on not only
the general American populace but other
lobbyists so they don't want those
things barred and so real reform isn't
going to happen what's what will happen
or Foe reforms you know things like you
have to sit down when you're you can't
sit down when you're eating your meal
yet this end up if you use your fingers
that's okay but if you use a fork it's
not okay when you're feeding a
congressman stupid stuff what I'm
talking about is a root and branch
borrowing these things now in terms of
the constitutionality of it North
Carolina borrowed their lobbyists the
state from giving any political
contributions and it was just upheld in
the Fourth Circuit that what they did is
constitutional and I think people have
to remember it's one thing to bar people
from giving money it's another thing to
tell somebody if you want to be nobody's
forcing anybody be a lobbyist by the way
or or take things from the federal
government but if you want to do that
then you need to give up certain things
too and I think those choices have been
held up previously as constitutional and
that's the basis on which I hope that
changes like this would be
constitutional you know a number of
people were caught up in this series of
scandals that sent you to prison and
only one of them member of Congress Bob
ney was a lawmaker was an elected
official do you feel that there's a
sense in which when Congress goes to fix
the problem the focus goes to the
lobbyists but not to themselves well I I
think you know the I can just tell you
what I was like when I saw a reform bill
coming we laughed we knew that we'd get
around it
we knew there would be loopholes and so
it doesn't really go after lobbyists or
there or the congressman part of the
problem and one of the reasons bob was
the only one who went to prison bob
apparently had a different issue that
wasn't related to mine he gave or he
took fifty thousand dollars in casino
chips from an Iranian businessman
apparently who wanted the government to
give permission to sell planes to Iran
now that act in doing it in the casino
in London is what I think on
Bob and Bob played by the way the Bobby
fought I'm not sure where water wound up
probably he would have been convicted
but in terms of the stuff with me nobody
else was indicted because a lot of the
congressional action is protected under
the Speech and Debate Clause in fact
William Jefferson who famously went to
prison because of $90,000 in his freezer
at home in money that was marked bills
from the FBI from a bribery operation
that he was running our extortion
operation if that freezer was in his
office he would be enjoying that money
today so there's a lot of protections
that they have in Congress that prevent
people the Justice Department from
really investigating them you have been
a filmmaker you've invested in a casino
cruise company you've launched a
restaurants there's talk now of a
reality TV show I don't know if that's
still alive what is next for you and
what are you working on now well I am
I'm working on the reality show I'm
working on some other television I'm
working on things that are related to
this space I'm trying app that we're
developing that brings people into this
world in a way that's fun challenging
and frightening I'm trying to do
everything I can to confront the way the
media are today in terms of the
opportunities for young people and
others to get educated it's not just
give a speech write a book go on
television there are other things that
have to be done now and so I'm trying to
accommodate this message and this
approach to that and hoping that in
doing so we'll be able to widen the
audience of people who care about it and
people are going to do something about
it so I'm I'm still a DD and still out
there doing a hundred things but a lot
of them are sort of sitting in this
space and trying to promote this and
where do you think our campaign finance
system is going next especially in the
wake of this Citizens United ruling
which has freed up corporate money and
which seems to have angered so many
people on both sides of the aisle well I
don't know where it's gonna go next I
hope I hope it goes to where I hope that
will go and others who want to get the
tainted money out of the system that in
bed would
remain to be seen it depends on the
American people pushing these members to
do the right thing again
campaign finances is a hot button but I
think we need to do is like I'm a
conservative and I've always been a
conservative but I'm working with
liberals also and progressives who have
the same view on the corruption side we
need to find those things where
conservatives and liberals can agree
we're not going to agree on campaign
finance public financing campaigns we
could agree on barring special interests
from giving money we need to find those
areas we need to push those areas and
hopefully solve the problems together
because in this atmosphere in Washington
if something is just from the rider just
on the Left it's not going to go through
well on that note I'll say thank you
very much thank you for having me